hello everyone i am in san diego
actually at comic con right now but i
have never gotten into a whole h panel
uh so i am catching up on two trailers
that they dropped today we have marvel
studios as black panther wakanda forever
official teaser which a lot of people
have been very excited about myself
included i'm really excited about this
movie um and we have another she-hulk
trailer as well so i thought i would
catch up on both of those of course a
lot of news also came out we got news
about the upcoming phases of the next uh
two years i think look like for the mcu
so a whole bunch of news they uh
definitely kind of
took the whole of comic-con by a storm
which isn't really a surprise um so
first let's watch this already has 1.8
million views the black panther wakanda
forever trailer make myself a little bit
smaller
okay let's do it no woman no crime
good song choice
[Music]
what a beautiful trailer
[Music]
it's also it it's this one's making me
emotional
i don't want to cry but i could
damn because of this
oh man
a lot of different stuff going on here
oh wow
is that kendrick
[Music]
have i not given
what a great mix
wow
and when i wake up
wow
just november
oh my god what a trailer because of
course they have to deal with chadwick
boseman's legacy
there's just so much in that that's so
important that you just can't mess up um
and i feel like this trailer in itself
is already a very good
homage
visually tons going on super interesting
obviously characters we know and where
they're at now
it looks like a whole lot of diverse
uh scenery doesn't just take place in
wakanda obviously but the music
just destroyed me mixing
those two songs together i imagine that
kendrick was responsible for that too um
i'm not sure if it's been confirmed if
he's also doing the music production on
what kind of forever but i imagine he is
because he
nailed it the first time around
wow
that yeah that like
that trailer made me emotional and gave
me goosebumps
i don't know that i've ever had a movie
trailer
make me want to tear up
amazing
very impressive um beautiful trailer i
will watch that again and soak up some
more details but like right now i'm just
like oh my god wow that was super
impactful and and visually stunning um
so let's jump up to something i expect
to have a very different effect on me
which is the official trailer for
she-hulk attorney at law the disney plus
series let's
check it out
make sure this is uh
1080p it's cool
i didn't love the first trailer didn't
love it didn't feel like it was for me
[Music]
wow jesus what the hell man still in
control no overwhelming feelings of rage
no a normal amount of rage you do revert
back to gen 4 when you sleep was the air
horn really necessary for comedy
absolutely
this is a multi-year journey you're
about to embark on
yeah who's your best friend
nikki
spandex spandex is your best friend
being a hulk asks for balance
you have so much more to learn
yes
so i'm clearly nailing it at all these
things
[Music]
if you want to go back to your life as a
lawyer i i respect that i think look i
usually try to keep commentary until
afterwards
i don't like this setup so there's
already things that i don't like about
this which is like i don't like the cg
of her face it just looks so video gamey
i feel like somehow bruce looks better
and that could just be like biased like
i could just be familiar with how he
looks
um the cg on her face i feel like she
doesn't even look like the human version
of herself it's really strange
uh
i don't love the comedy but the thing
that's actually bothering me about this
setup
is just making a character good at
everything
is never relatable
of course we have way more trailer to
get through he doesn't mean that
i did like that the comics do that too
though more eccentric superhumans are
coming out of the woodwork
we are going to launch a division for
them and i want the she-hulk to be the
facer
jennifer wolves
namaste
i have a serious conflict of interest
this man tried to kill my cousin bruce
yeah that's quite all right oh
people only care because i'm
representing emil bonski i think they
care cause they're like hey that girl's
green
jen do your thing good i really like
this outfit
[Music]
i'm not proud of this
miss walters we answer to a higher power
our universe is on the edge of a
precipice
i am a lawyer
we do things by the book
the book of the shanty no the book of
american
uh laws
whether you like it or not you're now a
superhero
let's do this
[Music]
you know that friend a lot of people
actually high school
who was way cooler than you were
attractive got all the attention from
everyone
hello
i think i'm jealous is that what i'm
feeling
[Music]
well hello there that's exciting um
that's cool we don't hate that reveal so
the thing with she-hulk i think i feel
the same way that i did beforehand and i
have read she-hulk comics i like
she-hulk the fourth wall break was a
very cool thing because that does happen
a lot in she-hulk comics and they are
funny um
some of the comedy stuff yeah it doesn't
appeal to me too much because i think
the vibe of this show is just not
necessarily for me
but i don't think that makes it bad
uh i feel like this show is very
specific audience
and i'm just not part of that audience
and that's totally completely fine um
that's how it feels like the the trailer
like
is definitely
already coming across as like it's about
interpersonal relationships and her
struggle in the spotlight
um i'm expecting it to have some rom-com
vibes it's just like a little bit more
light-hearted definitely had more
crossovers in there than i was expecting
and that's definitely cool i feel like
anybody who wants to make sure that
they're fully up to date with everything
the mcu is gonna need to watch this
series like
way bigger spectacle than i expected
though that sometimes concerns me in
terms of storytelling with marvel i feel
like sometimes it contains stories
uh are the ones that you can relate to
the most so
yeah i uh i can see there are bits of
conflict i'm not super sold on her
character
yeah the tone just isn't selling it for
me but again i don't think that means
it's bad i think it just means it's not
for me which is
totally 100 okay not everything has to
be for me
that is all right i'd love to see some
comments on this one see how people feel
about it
trailer was miles better than the first
i totally agree with that
also agree the the fourth wall worked
better than i expected
and daredevil obviously
cameos also awesome jen's fourth wall
breaking and the cousin tension between
her and bruce is hilarious and i love
the cousin tension so much again
her being like way more
powerful than bruce banner isn't
something that appeals to me i would
actually prefer her have to go through
like a learning process where she fails
a lot and it's like a
part of one type relationship but um it
seems like they kind of skipped over
there
definitely a step up from the first
trailer it's got me more excited for the
series i do agree
that it is definitely a lot better than
the first trailer
cgi isn't to the usual perfection but
the show itself looks like it'll carry
that yeah i hope they still iterate on
the cgi a little bit but that's not
usually how marketing works
looks like a ton of fun and actually
maybe the most movieish of the show so
far
i don't know about that
i have a feeling she's going to be a
total tank and a badass on the field in
the mcu's future that is definitely true
clearly set up for that
do agree that it it captures the
essential tone of the she-hulk in the
comics i do feel like they've nailed
that
um
[Music]
yeah it is it is definitely about a
trailer i think that i'm just not sold
on the on the show itself it's very hard
to sell me on a tv show though uh
i didn't even watch moon night
that's just me
just looks like a little bit too cheesy
i'm not super drawn into the conflict uh
which couldn't be like a more different
reaction from wakanda again totally just
my personal preference so i don't think
it looks bad i'm definitely not [ __ ]
on it
um
but that that what kind of forever
trailer
maybe that was what i did here wrong as
well was i watched a trailer that's like
brilliant
and super emotional and then jump to
something more light-hearted that could
have been it that could have been it
man what a great trailer i imagine that
the
comments on this one uh
chadwick boseman is the reason
where where we are with the sequel your
rest in peace my friend you are and
always will be our black panther
well the whole cast was hugging each
other after its trailer debut at sdcc
that's so nice
yeah i don't even know if i can read the
comments this is like messing me up this
movie's definitely gonna make me cry and
that does not happen often